[Music]
well the president has threatened to
close the u.s mexico border and cut aid
to various central american countries in
response to the massive caravan of
migrants
making its way slowly up from mexico
secretary defense general jim mattis has
also ordered hundreds of u.s troops
about 800
to the u.s mexico border in anticipation
of their arrival
roberto hernandez is an immigration
advocate who lives in san francisco
he says he's happy the migrants are
coming he joins us tonight roberto
thanks very much
for coming on i don't expect uh to
convince you
to change your views on immigration
we've talked many times i know what they
are
but i applaud you for being more honest
than most on the left in saying out loud
what you really want so i
i want to use you to inform our viewers
about the aims of
the left tell me what the justification
for this group coming here is if they
wanted asylum they could have applied in
the embassy in tagusagalpa
they're instead coming to our border are
they claiming that they're refugees
fleeing a war if so what war what is
the justification for this
good evening first of all let's go to
our history you know here in the
americas no let's not
let's just go to the question the world
okay look at all the europeans that came
here
this was native american land and
europeans came here
okay you've demonstrated an ignorance of
history sufficient that i don't want you
trying to educate us and then i just
want you to answer my question about
right now if that's okay if we just
stick to the question
what is the justification the legal
justification
for these people coming to our border
and not the us embassy in tagusagalpa
well if you look at the role of the
united states
in central america in nicaragua in
honduras in guatemala
and other countries in latin america the
united states has promoted wars
uh to protect corporate interests in a
lot of these countries
and so you have a lot of people who have
been affected by these wars
and it's caused poverty in a lot of
these countries
and currently there are is a political
climate in a lot of these countries
and people are coming here looking for a
refugee
so let's let's hold on no okay i'm going
to try and take you seriously united
nations
is what is supporting did you know that
the united nations it doesn't nothing
united nations does matters to me or
surprises
me but let me hold on let me just ask
you through the care of it i'm trying to
take you seriously
you said most of them in this the first
caravan are coming from honduras
what war specifically are you talking
about that the united states promoted
whose interests
were benefiting from that war and when
did that war end
what are you talking about specifically
specifically look at the the
role of the u.s government in honduras
i mean we can go here all day what war
are you talking about
so i want to move just give me the war
tell me when it understands
that okay let me ask you this have you
do you know of any involvement of the
u.s
in honduras see you what you're saying
is you don't really know what you're
going on
what you're saying is you don't really
know what you're talking about
but you're throwing out a topic
just to talk about but you would say i'm
trying i'm trying
i'm asking you i'm asking you
specifically
what war in honduras are you talking
about
that the united states inspired that
justifies this migrant caravan
what were when did that war end what
year what are you talking about or do
you not know
what i do okay let's look at the role of
the
military of the u.s currently in
honduras
no but you said there was a war so
you're totally ignorant of the history
of honduras but you are lecturing
us about our responsibility to let these
people in because of a war that we
started but you can't tell us what war
or what year it ended i think that's
what you're saying and
not only that but it's the involvement
of the u.s
in honduras and central america and
we've talked about it so
obviously history is not your subject
let's go to something and that's fine
i'm not sure we're disagreeing with what
you're talking about
he is supporting his care event why
would they not
be supporting and helping these people
and not accountability
i can't imagine why the u.n does a lot
of things that the us
uh uh should got it stop let me ask you
from letting these people come here
let me we're gonna change the category
to the 200 category let's see if you can
answer this
okay san francisco has now announced
that
illegal aliens people who have no right
to be here will be allowed to vote in
local school board elections you live
in the city you think this is a great
idea do you think americans who sneak
into
other people's countries ought to be
allowed to vote in their elections
well let's look at how many um uh uh uh
white people live in mexico the mexican
government doesn't harass them
but let's let's look are they allowed to
vote in elections people
did look how many people did not vote in
this last election
look look at the numbers okay
i would say as a performance artist
you're talented but i just want to get
one straight answer are americans who
sneak into other people's countries
without permission allowed do they have
a right to vote in those countries
elections do i have a right
to sneak into mexico and announce that i
get to vote there and if you don't let
me you're a racist is that a human right
that i possess
so let's get it clear in san francisco
these individuals that are being allowed
to vote
are only voting for the election for the
members of the board of education
another question
all right these these people right
should have the
right to vote specifically for those who
are going to make
policies and decisions affecting their
children
okay so i asked you a couple simple
questions you couldn't come up with an
answer text me later if those answers
come to you okay roberto i appreciate it
thank you very much